welcome everyone thank you for joining
us today I'm Christy Lake Chief people
officer at twilio and I am excited to
have the opportunity to talk to our
special guest Simon sinek about a trend
we're seeing in the people world and
across the globe the great resignation
its impact on how we do business how we
lead and how we continue to create
sustainable organizations the great
resignation as some are calling it is
this phenomenon of employees that are
voluntarily leaving their jobs and
record numbers across almost every
industry geography we're seeing it
globally
in April of 2021 about a year into the
pandemic we started to see a surge of
workers quitting in the U.S more than 24
million people quit their jobs between
April and September of 2021. in July the
UK hit an all-time high of over 1
million job vacancies nearly a quarter
of Singapore workers are planning to
leave their current employer in the
first half of 2022. a Microsoft survey
of more than 30 000 Global workers
showed that 41 percent of employees were
considering considering quitting or
changing professions within the year a
great resignation indeed we've all seen
it or felt it this Exodus from the
workforce maybe you or a friend or
family member or someone on your team
have quit their job perhaps you've had
disruptions to how you do business how
you had to wait in longer lines for
service due to Staffing shortages what's
driving this employees are burnt out one
study of knowledge workers across eight
countries found that 71 percent had
experienced burnout in the last year to
escape it they're leaving their employer
or their Workforce altogether and
experts expect the quitting to continue
so what does this mean for employees and
how will employers and you as Leaders
attending today respond here with us to
discuss how you can create a workplace
where employees are motivated to stay
and do their best work is best
best-selling author of start with Y and
the infinite game Simon sinek
welcome Simon it is wonderful to have
you here with us today you are known for
your wildly successful books and TED
talks but a lot of people may not know
that you got your start in ethnography
which is studies of human cultures and
societies well my background is not an
ethnography as a chief people officer in
many ways I'm studying people and our
culture here at twilio every day I've
been a huge fan of your work it's been
extremely impactful and influential in
the people world going back to start
with why so it's all the more exciting
to have you to talk about this really
important topic that I think every
leader in every industry is really
grappling with and coming to terms with
the world has changed a ton in the last
two years including meaningfully the way
we work people were sent home to work
remotely some are coming back to the
office is it back to what it used to be
is it something you know better and new
so I'm really curious just to start off
what questions should employers consider
as they determine what this future work
looks like for them
um well good to see you Christy uh
thanks for having me
um so I think what's so fascinating
about the working world right now is
that it is in complete flux everything's
been thrown up into the air and quite
frankly we're not 100 sure where all the
pieces are going to land and I think a
lot of things are on the table people
are questioning you know do we need a
corporate headquarters or not you know
that's being debated you know what is
the role of
um uh remote work you know if it's
possible why should I come to the office
I've heard stories of people picking up
the phone and calling their their CEOs
calling their bosses and saying oh it's
so fantastic you know our family's
living the dream we've we've moved to
Florida you know and the companies like
but we're in Kansas you know and they're
like I know it's just wonderful we've
always wanted to live in Florida now we
can and like nobody asked do you mind if
we've moved to Florida
um and and so I think a lot of companies
are like do we say anything is that a
problem but uh we wanted everybody to
come back to the office
um and the answer is we're kind of have
to wait and see and so when you ask what
should companies be asking themselves I
think they have to put everything on the
table and ask themselves what is the
future of work one of the things that I
think will happen is there's just going
to be more flexibility so in the past uh
sort of pre-ar comfort with remote work
you know you'd have to ask permission if
I can work from home next Thursday and I
think what's going to happen in the
future is people are going to pick up
the phone and send an email and saying
hey I'm just going to work from home
today and everything will be fine like
everybody everybody will be fine with
that
um but I'm I I think everything's on the
table and those discussions have to
happen and and you cannot dig your your
heels in and say well this is the way it
used to be and this is the way it's
going to stay it's just not going to
work out well
yeah and I think that's the fundamental
question that companies are wrestling
with it's these Notions of productivity
and mentorship and learning and
connection and if we don't have the
constructs that we worked in previously
where you could take for granted the
hallway conversation and the the water
cooler chat how do you replace that with
something new and better and so I'm
curious what do you make of of what
feels like the generally accepted belief
that connection suffers that
relationships suffer like what do
companies make of all of this
well of course that's true
um uh you know we're social animals and
we need human interaction
um you know one of the reasons mental
health has become such a significant
topic uh right now is because we're
disconnected and we have been
disconnected from people who've seen
kids suffering we've seen Rises and all
kinds of outbursts on airplanes and
domestic violence is on the rise you
know so their mental health is a is a
real thing because we've been so
disconnected from from other people
um you know Isaac Stern the the virtuoso
violinist said music is what happens
between the notes well trust is what's
built between the meetings and as you as
you pointed out it's like it's the
little Chit Chat walking into the
conference room and the little Chit Chat
and the meeting that continues after the
meeting you know it's the bumping into
somebody in the hallway and be like oh I
meant to tell you or stopping someone
and saying hey you want to grab a coffee
or lunch and it's all those seemingly
innocuous little interactions over the
course of time that build up and build
relationships build Trust in a digital
world that's gone those don't exist we
only have the meetings and so when you
talk about what can be what can replace
those things that's better the answer is
nothing nothing can replace and be
better than genuine real human
connection
um and I think what a lot of companies
don't recognize is if you do have a
distributed Workforce and you're okay
with remote work you actually have to do
more to create relationships you can't
just allow it to be organic like it is
at the office so for example one of the
things we do
we have a Monday morning huddle where
the whole team comes together and we say
what's on our heart and mind
and
um we answer either a funny or poignant
question that the Huddle leader will ask
um and we spent about 45 minutes to an
hour uh on this call and there is no
discussion of work there's no talking
deadlines or performances or projects
nothing it is strictly human connection
and we actually learn about each other
and you know we find out that people
have kids we find out that somebody's uh
a parent is in the hospital because they
talked about how they had a difficult
weekend we talk about we find out that
somebody loves cooking and we're finding
relationship and it is a huge help we've
had many people who've joined our team
throughout covet who've never met and
this has been a fantastic way for them
to meet each other we're also a big fan
of work sessions where you turn on Zoom
you just leave the the picture in the
corner and you just work together even
if you're not working together uh
um or at little social times where you
have you know a drink together on a
Friday or something but we actually have
to do these things prescriptively that
used to happen organically and of course
you know uh you know covered
restrictions notwithstanding
um you know off-sites now have even more
importance and it becomes less about the
person who's speaking on the stage or
whatever you know uh meeting we have at
the upside and it becomes about the
people getting to spend time together
I love that and yeah I mean I I feel
like the conversation has really shifted
more towards this how do we with intent
craft opportunities for people to come
together whether it's your Monday
morning huddle or your work on Zoom
session
um and and it is really I think
pressuring companies to think about what
does that look like for them
um related to that
um you know a lot has has certainly been
written in the belonging and inclusion
space that whilst we've been working
from home more broadly
underrepresented populations have have
not had some of the experiences that
they would typically have whether it's
microaggressions or different things
that happen throughout the day and so
how do you think that
looks in the future when populations are
more able to opt out of the in person
whether I'm you know a parent or any
other identity that would choose to be
home more often where do you think that
Nets out over time when people are given
the opportunity some in some out does
that hurt does that help
well I think what we're talking about is
empathy you know which is which is it's
a it becomes even more important I mean
you know this as an HR practitioner
which is the importance of listening and
finding out where people stand and how
they feel
um you know we we are social we're we're
emotional animals and we react and make
decisions based on our feelings which
include ego fear anxiety all the things
um and sometimes and we know this from
our personal relationships sometimes our
the decisions we make based on our
emotions aren't necessarily the best
forever but that's how we feel now and
so I think it becomes very important
when somebody makes a request that is
different than what the company was
expecting or intending that that you sit
down and you listen rather than saying
No this is how we're doing it you want
to find out you want that person needs
to feel seen and heard
um one of the uh you know I'm a great
believer that the world is always
balanced I don't believe in good and bad
you know I think that you know for
there's always a cost for the things
that go well
um and there's always Lessons Learned or
something to be gained from when things
are go wrong and I think one of the
things that happened with um definitely
with covid and the murder of George
Floyd is it held up a mirror and it
revealed a lot of things that we either
didn't see or only some of us saw as you
said uh like microaggressions and it
became starkly clear to see the
difference and recognize I get this here
and not there and so I think one of the
huge advantages is we can point to these
things and talk about them rather than
just be able rather than just what was
before saying I feel uncomfortable but I
don't know what it is and rather I can
explain to you what's making me
uncomfortable
um and I think the the idea of working
together to find to find common ground
and like I said most importantly that
people who raise their hand and say
something's wrong or I'm uncomfortable
that they are made to feel seen and
heard is absolutely vital so empathy has
to run through through all of this but I
think there's huge advantages that come
out of this and I think we can improve
corporate culture as a result
yeah I'd love to hear that and I I think
it puts pressure on all of us as
employers to really think about creating
Equitable experiences whether it's a
remote first or some hybrid combination
of how do we ensure that folks that may
choose different paths still have access
to you know Career Development and
opportunities because at the end of the
day you know we're here to do good work
and hopefully continue to learn and grow
and so I think the the pressure is
definitely on is speaking of which much
has been has been written and
experienced this massive shift in what I
would call the power Dynamic that it
used to be the employer kind of you know
mandated these are the terms you know
you're in Monday to Friday and you know
we expect you to be there for whatever
and now employees are saying no thanks
I'm really keen on going to Florida and
that's what this looks like for me and
for for some Industries and for some
employers
that I think has really created some
fear you know are my people being
productive what are they doing when I
can't see them and so how do we change
this mindset instead of you know this is
something that you know you must do to
wow we really need to you know
empathetically listen to our employees
and figure out how do we create this new
thing that's you know better and
different but still great
well we it's it's a shifting balance
right you know Face Time used to be a
thing where we determine how uh how hard
you worked or how devoted you were to
the company based on you know what time
you showed up and what time you left and
yet stories abound of people you know
who sat at their desks and did nothing
they just needed to have the face time
so that their bustle that they were
there you know because that was the the
metric of of the company
um so you know you have productive and
unproductive people at work and not at
work you know with it and so we just had
to shift slightly that um that our
ability not to see them you know we we
have to learn to trust
um which is which is a hard one one of
the things that I find really
interesting is I used to be I've pulled
back on you know I used to be like I
don't want you working on nights and I
don't want you working on weekends I
want people to have their time because
when we had a traditional nine to five
sort of mentality I wanted people to let
go of work and have personal time I've
actually pulled back from saying those
things because now I don't know when
people want to work maybe they want to
wake up late or you know go to the gym
in the morning and start working at 10
or 11 but then they'll work to seven or
eight because they're happy to do that
and so now I think uh we have to learn
to allow people to figure out their own
schedules now the missing pieces is
communication what must happen for any
employee who wants to have an uh a
schedule that is different or
alternative to what the company's
expectations are or what the standard is
is they have to communicate the
communication is different than making a
demand or just sort of making an
announcement but rather like hey you
know I'm happy to work uh later
um I really want to have my mornings to
get my kids ready to go to school
um uh would it be okay if I started work
at 11 or 10 which means I just wouldn't
I wouldn't be on any meetings can we
push meetings past 10 o'clock and it's a
discussion because the answer is yeah
probably you know we almost all
situations there's a very very
comfortable uh agreement that everybody
can be comfortable with I think what
both employees and employers get struck
by is is the demand in the announcement
like you will do this and that goes both
ways I think we just want to be heard
and seen as I said before and um but
communication has to happen there has to
be communication
um because like I said I think I like I
think a lot of them
employees feel
um embarrassed to ask or afraid to ask
but if you have good leadership and
somebody who cares about creating a
positive working environment they should
be open to pretty much everything
yeah I agree I I always say expectation
management makes the world go around
it's like here's what you can expect for
me and is that cool does that work for
you or should we make a different you
know contract so to speak I I was
thinking about it and I always thinking
about it like like a personal
relationship like you can't just come
home to your to your partner and and say
this is what I'm going to be doing like
it doesn't work that way like even if
it's legitimate and fair they may get
defensive and so it's communication you
say would it be okay if or I was
thinking about and you involved them and
include them in the decision and you get
exactly what you want it's very similar
as you said expectation management and
effective communication are important in
all relationships personal and
professional
absolutely I mean you can try that route
but it doesn't tend to work over
men and candidly we've seen companies
that have come out with uh this is how
it's going to be and see Myriad
companies you know pull back from that
and re you know retrench and you know
actually it's not going to be five or
three it's going to be more like you
tell us what do you want
um which leads me to to the next topic
which is Recruitment and Retention so
this this shift in power the rebalancing
the more engaged you know flexible
um you know way that that folks are
connecting now it's really impacting the
Recruitment and Retention of employees
and the the job market is like I have
never seen you know I got my little Auto
notification this morning you know in
the U.S alone over 10 million open jobs
right now and so it is very clear in
today's labor market it is a job Seekers
market and so how should companies think
about you know what are people looking
for and how do we differentiate from the
company down the street
um especially in such a dynamic time
when we're all trying to figure out what
that future looks like
well I think we have to ask ourselves
why you know why is the Great
resignation happening you know uh and um
a commentary about people getting you
know their government checks yes that's
a small percentage that's not the
majority you know somebody decides you
know what this is not for me I want to
follow my dreams those those are there
too but I don't think that is explains
the mass uh the mass Exodus
um I I think uh one of the things we're
not talking about that this is very much
an indictment against years and years
and years of of of uh substandard
corporate culture where for years and
years and years we you know companies
have
um taken advantage of or mistreated uh
Frontline workers they've paid them less
because they could because they needed
the money and they needed the job and
they could get away with it
um where corporate culture wasn't
necessarily great it was just fine like
how's your work it's fine like it's not
toxic like I'm getting yelled at every
day it's just fine and you know would I
like to quit I would like to quit but
the unknown is way scarier than the dev
level I know and so we stayed put and
then covet happened and a lot of people
got furloughed or laid off or you know
or even just had the fear of losing
their jobs
um and they made it through okay and all
of a sudden the unknown became a lot
less scary and so faced with going to
work to a place that I know doesn't see
me as a human being they just see me as
a number to be calculated on a
spreadsheet and the unknown I'll take
the unknown and so I think this is as I
said before a huge indictment for
decades of companies uh not focusing on
strong corporate culture quite frankly
and not seeing their people as people
and so this is a correction we know
stock market Corrections happen when
they're grossly unbalanced well this is
a correction in the labor market because
it's been grossly unbalanced so you know
for for those that underpay pay clearly
is is one of the things but I think also
um as you said before like when you join
our company we see you as a human being
we want to see you grow we want to see
you learn we want to put you on a path
to help you uh to achieve what you want
to achieve and whether you stay here for
a short timer a long time we want you to
feel that the time you spent with us was
worth it and you're a better version of
yourself because you were with us and I
think companies have no choice but to
invest in their people to invest in
learning in leadership one of the things
that I find astonishing is how little
leadership education there is in
companies you know we give people tons
of training when they join the company
to teach them the platforms and the
products and we give them tons of
training when they're we give them you
know mentors and make an apprentice all
so that they can be good at their job
but as they make their way through the
organization we give them little to
nothing we don't teach people listening
skills we don't teach people how to give
and receive feedback we don't teach
people how to have an effective
confrontation or an uncomfortable
conversation you know we don't teach
those skills they are just skills
um and when you wait many many years of
not doing that what you get is exactly
the situation we're in now it is worth
noting that the companies with very
strong corporate cultures who have been
investing in these things are suffering
a lot less yes they're still having
people leave to follow their dreams and
those things but we you know those are
positive but the ones who are uh you
know giving a certain finger as they're
walking out the door and saying I don't
need this
um those companies are suffering uh
those situations a lot less because
their people have gratitude
uh I had a I had a manager once who will
chuckle if she is listening to this who
um coined the phrase she said we have
generations of managers that were raised
by wolves which to your point haven't
gone through the formal training and had
the years of experience to really become
excellent people managers who understand
how to work collaboratively and treat
their teams well and help help them grow
and develop and I think it makes a ton
of sense that the Day of Reckoning for
that is now upon us and so it's it's
interesting I mean to your point you
know maybe some people did check out
entirely and follow their dreams in a
different path but broadly I've been
calling this period the great reshuffle
because yes people are leaving companies
but they are joining companies on the
other side and and I think lots of that
to your point it is you know it is
really shining a light on companies that
perhaps haven't been great at you know
treating their people well well but I'm
curious your thoughts you called it
almost like a market correction and when
I think of those I think okay there was
a defined period of time you could track
the stock market see what was happening
and then you could see when recovery
happens and so are you thinking of this
period of time of the great resignation
the great reshuffle as a point in time
and a correction or is this more of like
a seismic systemic shift that you think
is going to be enduring this this power
rebalance you know all of it uh so a
system a system corrects when it's out
of balance right and so whether it's a
stock market or a labor market and so
it's it's woefully out of balance and it
doesn't go like this it goes like that
um and that's what we're experiencing
that's what we're in the middle of which
is it's it's a complete swing to the
other side
um and usually what happens is we look
at the ills that cause that cause the
imbalance in the first place you know
after the Great Depression they passed
they passed the glass-steagall ACT to
prevent another Great Depression from
happening
um you know they put in all kinds of
controls on our economy uh uh and it
worked by the way and so what I think is
important is is for people to go back to
the source it's it's not to look at the
symptom and treat the symptom right
because then we were not going to
correct it we'll just throw money at the
situation which is a short-term
correction it'll fix the problem only in
the short term but it doesn't make
people feel better when they come to
work
um I think we need to look back at how
we have been operating if if you're a
company that is gone through it's going
through where you're losing labor and
you can't get them back or you're losing
teammates I mean the fact that we call
people labor you know that that should
that should set up a red flag for us as
well the fact that we're losing
teammates and that they and they're not
coming back let's look at a history of
how we fought them you know when they
asked for reasonable wages did we fight
them when when they asked to be seen and
heard did we put up barriers
um did we invest in their personal
growth did we promote the toxic High
performer into a leadership position
and then they became a toxic leader and
Justified it because their performance
was good or did we promote somebody who
had good natural leadership positions
regardless of whether they were one of
our top performers or not they knew how
to help others work at their best like
we have to look at our promotion
structures we have to look at our
incentive structures do we only
incentivize People based on individual
performance is that accidentally
breeding Behavior inside the company
that we find obnoxious like where people
are stabbing each other in the back to
get to make themselves get ahead are we
incentivizing teamwork I think it is
incumbent upon companies to really do a
um uh uh you know uh what do you call it
forensic dive
um in into the way they have been doing
business to try and understand what
people are emotionally reacting to and
where they have the courage now to leave
and certainly we see a fair amount of
short-term response that's oh it's you
know summer Fridays and and different
things and all good ideas and I'm sure
have Merit but to your point really
fixing the systems and shifting them
towards positive Equitable approaches to
all of these moments that matter to to
all of us in our careers
um is so important it brings me to
another which you you touched on earlier
um mental health and burnout and
increasingly companies will look at that
and say well this is the thing and there
are all these other things that are
longer term and take a while to actually
you know correct and make better but in
the short term you just hear so much
about burnout or you know I know the I'm
certain you read you know last year Adam
Grant wrote that great article about
languishing and this notion that we're
just stuck in the middle of it all
whether you're a caregiver or whatever
your personal situation is
what is the way through this what do you
think to not treat the symptom throwing
a Friday off at somebody that's enduring
you know longer term burnout is probably
not going to be the solution what do you
think about it all so one of the great
things about covid is that nobody not a
single person was smart enough or strong
enough to escape any kind of Trauma from
it
um that's what some people had it soon
some people had it later some people had
pieces of it and it sort of continues to
be a steady drip some people had a you
know a a an intense depression
um but we all went through it which
means I hope that we have more
understanding and empathy for the
condition you know for for mental health
that that this is a real thing that
people go through and sometimes they
can't explain it you know I think very
often we want to know what the reason
what the cause is like you know is it
because you know uh you know you have a
sick family member is it because you
broke up with your your your boyfriend
or girlfriend like we're always looking
for the cause and sometimes it's not
it's not there
um and I think it goes back to what we
said before and this is probably going
to be a theme in in all of these uh uh
questions which is it goes back to
empathy which is which is it's it's not
for us to fix it's us for whole it's us
for it's for us to hold space
you know
um you know there's a very simple
question for for a leader which is are
you okay
and this is something we have to do
whether we think someone's okay with us
we think somebody's not okay
um a lot of people can mask
um how they're actually feeling they
double down on work to compensate you
notice it's just because somebody's
productive and their performance is up
doesn't mean they're they're not
struggling
um and so I you know to create a space
where you can say are you okay and
actually care about the answer is a huge
test for leadership and by the way the
best way to achieve that is for the
leaders uh to lead by example and that's
very scary for for a lot of people in
leadership positions we talk about
vulnerability but the reality is if
they're not modeling the behavior other
people won't follow it you know if we
say you know we want to know how you how
you feel but I'm always in Tip-Top shape
and I'm always have all the answers and
I'm always strong well then I can
guarantee you that creates an
environment in which people actually are
afraid to be honest and so uh uh it's
it's necessary for people in leadership
positions whether it's on a huddle or
some other form
or maybe you know to a few people and
say Hey listen I'm I'm struggling this
week and I just want I want to apologize
and say please be patient with me you
know I'm probably I'm I know I'm not at
my best I I think I might actually take
a Friday off because I'm I'm I'm I'm
having a hard time this week and I'm not
sure what it is but I know that I'm not
myself for Elita to be able to say that
creates an environment for somebody on
the team to come and say the same thing
and then we can hold space for them but
if the leader's lying hiding and faking
every day then all we're doing is
creating an environment where our people
will lie and fake every day and so you
know I think this idea of of leading
with vulnerability of and vulnerability
doesn't mean you're you know that
doesn't mean you're weak you know all it
means is you're willing to say something
that makes you uh like admit a mistake
ask for help say you don't understand
something or admit struggle that's all
it is that's all it is with the
confidence that people will be there to
hold space for you and support you and
if the leader is willing to do that it's
remarkable what we can create around us
for the people who work there
I want to unpack this notion of
leadership
we have seen a rapid acceleration in the
expectations of being a great leader
it's not enough anymore to direct the
work to hold people accountable to give
feedback Chuck
leaders in the last two years have been
called upon to do things they never did
before whether it's whether it's the
vulnerability you talk about and really
inviting people into to your world to
help them understand how you're coping
and how you're working through things
but leading with empathy checking in on
folks mental health and wellness
understanding do they have a sick parent
they're looking after how do I help you
balance some of these things that well
and truly go beyond the confines of what
traditional work relationships were now
that work is like hi I'm speaking to you
from my dining room right now right it's
a very different world that we're all in
and so what do you think about modern
leadership and and is that sort of whole
person and empathetic leadership
is is that where we will be or do you
see some retrenchment where folks are
like hey I actually would like some
separation between work and home and let
me just do my thing and I don't want to
talk to you about what's going on with
Grandma or whatever it may be
you know the answer is there's no one
size fits all
um
and and when we create a corporate
culture that that leads with empathy
where people are put at the center
rather than performances put in the
center
um you know some people you know leaders
have bad habits but sometimes um
teammates have bad habits you know I've
been doing this for 20 years leave me
alone I don't want to tell you my
feelings you know and we can't expect
everybody to change in this at the same
time it's like if we all go to the gym
at the same time we won't all get in in
shape at the same time you know we're
we're different and so part of a Journey
part of a leadership Journey for uh for
people in leadership positions is
patience
and the willingness to hold space for
them even when they're resistant because
we know it's good for them even if they
don't know it's good for them
um and uh and that's okay
um and sometimes
um uh uh it it it it just again I think
one of the things that's drastically
missing here is that leadership is a
skill
and the best leaders are students of
leadership all the best leaders I've
ever met the ones who literally what
they've accomplished what they've done
the the love and loyalty that they
command they do have the the sort of the
the the the credibility to say I think I
know what I'm doing they don't
they read articles they read books they
watch talks they have conversations
about it constantly they it's like no
there's no such thing as a perfect
parent parents are constantly talking to
other parents and reading books about
little things that happen that they're
trying to be better parents and things
that happen that they didn't expect well
leadership's the same as a constant
education of the best leaders are
constantly learning they should be doing
it on the by themselves
um they should be doing it informally
forming a book club for example I'm a
huge fan of book clubs for companies
that say well we can't afford a
leadership curriculum like you can
afford a book you know
um and have book clubs just voluntary
you know people who volunteer to come
and discuss a few chapters every few
weeks
but also for companies to now provide
that training
um and I and I listed some of the the
the things before you know which is we
we cannot expect that people know how to
lead if we don't teach them how to lead
like we can't expect somebody to know
how to do anything if we don't teach
them how to do anything you know
um and and how long does it take for a
kid to walk like you know we know
there's a process and you follow the
process and some kids walk early and
some kids walk a little later but we
know 100 of people will learn to walk
you know it's like it's just a process
the same everybody can learn how to lead
doesn't all happen at the same time but
we have to teach
um we have to provide forum for
discussion
um and whether we like it or not it
happens in the company you know we would
love it to happen in high school we
would love it to happen in universities
or mbas and it didn't they just the
college systems are terrible absolutely
abysmal they're teaching leadership they
teach management
maybe there's a leadership class with
one you know okay leadership Professor
um and so the responsibility falls on
the company whether you like it or not
yeah that's that's such a good point and
Leadership like all other things is
trial and error and you know there is no
one-size-fits-all but I think folks that
are in positions of leadership right now
are really grappling with how do I do
this in the context of everything that
we're we're dealing with right now
um something else going back to the
burnout topic I mean when we think
globally
the the trends and the the market
correction in you know the space of of
work is definitely upon us we see
broadly in Europe a lot of these right
to disconnect laws
even here I'm based in California I
believe you are today as well you know
there's some legislation that's being
proposed about a four-day Work Week
whether it passes or not you know
unlikely but but we're seeing now
governments stepping in and saying wow
we have we have an issue here and it's
time to do something about it
do you see that as a solve putting these
mandates because because I'm reflecting
on what you said earlier it's like you
may have someone on your team that's hey
I go to the gym at 10 A.M and that's my
happy place I'm equally happy to be
online at 8pm and so do you see these
government Corrections being part of the
answer here you know usually when
government involves it gets involved
it's they're considering
um one side and not the other and they
usually over under legislate you know
it's and it's either you know government
never gets it right it's over here or
it's over here you know he's you know
he's gonna piss off somebody you know
and and I think like so let's let's just
game out the four hour work week okay so
there's there's a movement for a
four-hour work week in California and if
Government legislates it it will create
a bunch of unforeseen problems for like
customer service things or you know you
know where you have to react to things I
mean who knows this I can guarantee they
haven't thought of every consideration
but what it does say is that companies
needs to start asking themselves should
we be considering a four hour work week
and how does a four hour work week work
for us because
the government won't get it right
but but we may be interested in this
and so I think when these things show up
in legislation what it says in some
people's mind and people are asking the
questions
um and I think it's I think instead of
knee-jerking and just fighting against
these things I think companies need to
you know leadership needs to sit down
and say should we have a four-hour work
week how would that look for us how
would it work for us would it work for
our kind of business what if we can only
give it you know what if it works really
well for some people but not all the
people then how do we make sure
everybody you know it creates a lot of
questions that I think we have to go
through the process of trying to figure
it out and if the answer is you know we
could do something again involve the
people are you are you are you
interested which then raises a whole new
question which I think is also uh uh
something that's showing up in in
distributed workforces is what does a
full-time job mean
and and you know uh older and when I say
older I mean in age uh leaders are
really struggling to understand that you
know I if you're a full-time employee
and I'm giving you Insurance then you're
not allowed to do anything else
but we don't know that because we know
that in the past if you work from nine
to five you can do whatever you want
your nights and weekends you can have 15
jobs if you want as long as you're
working nights and weekends but if it's
not nine to five anymore how does that
look
can you have two full-time jobs is that
wrong
and a lot of young people cannot
distinguish they're saying you
you say I can do my work whenever I want
I work from home you have no problems
with my performance what do you care
when I work and where I work
so what if you're giving me Insurance
thank you very much I do good work for
you
and I can guarantee you that young
people are having these conversations
and they are not encumbered by sort of
traditional way of work working and they
have much more of a blank sheet of paper
now I'm not saying it's right or wrong
I'm saying that it's best to have these
discussions yourself because if you're
not having the discussion yourself then
then the hammer of legislation will
probably come down and solve a few
problems and create a bunch more
um
I believe legislation happens and should
happen when there's Massive Resistance
and there is something that needs to
happen and for whatever reason companies
dig in and refuse to do it I can give
you plenty of examples of great versions
of legislation but I think when it comes
to regulating what a work day looks like
I think companies need to having start
having serious conversations and start
in reimagining again as I said at the
very beginning of this which is which is
it's all in flux everything is in the
air and there is no certainty right now
nobody knows what the future of work is
going to look like none of us every it's
like everything's been tossed up and
everybody's looking up wondering well we
can be a company that just Waits
where is it going to land or we can be a
company that's actually pioneering and
innovating with the future work could
and should look like and by the way
we're doing it with our people we're not
doing it by dictatorship like this is
what's going to happen but rather we're
working with our people and we're all
figuring out what works and what
actually makes for a really great place
to work where you can actually be really
productive and do really well as a
company as well where we can all take
pride that we are Reinventing what the
future of work looks like together and
I'd rather to happen at a company level
than at a government level
yeah I agree
um and by the way thank you for
validating the world in which I live
which is complete uncertainty nobody has
the answer and we're all trying to
figure it out I feel very seen in this
moment
um and and to that end you know I'm I'm
actually reflecting back I remember
everybody wants you to tell you what
it's going to be right
yeah yeah like please give us the
Playbook I I don't know when it came out
but it feels like it has to have been
like almost 10 years ago there were all
of these predictions about what the
future of work was going to be and I
remember there being so much talk about
the gig economy and you know as it
started Uber and you know delivery
services started coming online and that
became more of a reality it was like oh
you can have this side hustle and the
day job but no one in like corporate you
know World imagined a gig economy where
you would have your software developer
who also worked for ideally not a
competitor but another of those types of
Enterprises and we've seen these
articles of people having two jobs
during this period of time now
personally I'm a little more tenured and
I can't imagine having a second job or a
side Hustle but but for folks earlier in
career it's definitely something they're
thinking about so I think it's just
really interesting to hear you talk
about they're re-contracting you didn't
use that word that's my application but
of what work looks like and and what is
okay in the confines of what we expect
of you and are you a free agent other
than that I mean it is it's a it's a
Brave New World out there and and the
answer is there's advantages and
disadvantages
and I think where it becomes dangerous
and Insidious is is when there's a lack
of communication when people are lying
hiding and faking you know
um where a team member goes off on
moonlights but they're Moonlighting when
there's an expectation that they're
going to show up you know to do certain
things for one company for their for
their what let's call them their primary
employer
um and uh and it's that it's the line
hiding and faking and things that you
can get away with two things
simultaneously because poor performance
will suffer and and people will start
asking questions and it'll start with
are you okay but I can guarantee you
can't keep these things secret we live
in an online world it's all going to
show up online
um you know um and I think to Simply
raise your hand and say I have an
opportunity it's not a com you know it's
not a direct competition but I want to
talk to you if this is if this is
realistic you know can you help me try
and figure this out because it's
something I would like to do
um and it's it's really about
communication and people are afraid of
communication and this opens up an
entirely new conversation
about a young generation that's coming
to work and I think one of the things
that if we do not address it now it'll
only create problems for both the team
member and the employer and the company
um which is uh it's it's a generation
that's actually very uncomfortable with
confrontation
right
um and you know disproportionately High
number of of young people who break up
with somebody who they've been dating
for four or five months by ghosting them
you know or they'd rather they'd rather
have difficult conversations over text
rather than in person if you're in a
relationship and you're fighting right
um and uh or leaving alternative voice
memos at each other rather than having a
conversation and so one of the things
that we're we're seeing is like I'll
give you a real life example that I've
heard of a few times you know
um somebody quits in sometimes dramatic
fashion
um and sends an angry email that you you
don't appreciate me you don't pay me
enough
never occurred to them to Simply call up
their boss and say hey I'd like a raise
please
you know and that the choice between
having an uncomfortable conversation or
making that request in a in a in a
constructive way
is so uncomfortable that they choose
quitting
um uh and I've seen this happen a lot
um and so I think it becomes important
to us that if we aren't teaching these
skills of how to have uncomfortable
conversations how to speak up for
yourself how to talk about you know
creating an arrangement that may be
different from what my boss is used to
from the 20 years that they've been
working
um and how we can work together to
Fashion the future of work if we don't
actually start teaching those skills and
having those conversations that what we
what we're going to end up with is
people just quitting because not because
it's a bad corporate environment it's
because they don't know how to have a
conversation to talk about something
that's uncomfortable difficult or or
make a request I mean you and I are old
enough that you know if we go back now
if you go back to like it's really funny
if you go back to like the 50s or 60s
you never asked for a raise but you
didn't quit either you just remained
unhappy
right and then we reach a time period
where no no no no I'm asking for the
raise you know I refuse to remain
unhappy but we're now in a period where
um I I'm not going to ask for the raise
and I'm not going to remain I'm happy
I'm just gonna leave I'm just gonna
ghost I'm just gonna go which if you
know uh which again it's an employee
market right now uh uh and so in the
short term yeah you'll probably land
another job and you'll be okay that
again it's gonna it's gonna find a
balance is everything we're living in is
short term even if short term is the
next few years
um and I I think it's if we're talking
about helping people grow and become
better versions of themselves forever
then I think the skills that we teach
won't only benefit them and work it
benefits them at home in other words
that young person that we teach how to
have a difficult conversation and having
how to have an effective confrontation
so they can ask for a raise and probably
get it if they're if they're good that
skill set comes home too where I learn
how to have a conversation with my
partner in something uncomfortable
um you know that conversation that that
skill set goes to the way I treat my
children and treat my friends so we're
making better human beings here uh it
just so happens that that it benefits
the uh the company as well
um absolutely but we got to teach the
skills we got to teach the skills
we have a lot of work to do
um this brings me to another topic
um You released a book recently which I
promised you we wouldn't talk about but
the infinite game and you talk about
this concept of trusting teams and this
creating an environment where people can
work at their natural best can have
these open conversations hopefully we've
taught them the skill of how to ask for
that which they you know would like to
have happen but what is it what does it
look like for people to be working at
their natural best and how can employers
create this environment
so one of my favorite uh definitions of
what a trusting team looks like and I
think it's a story I tell in the book
um it's I went on a business trip to Las
Vegas and they back when we had business
trips and uh uh and the they were very
nice they put me up at the Four Seasons
in Las Vegas which is a beautiful hotel
and the reason it's a beautiful hotel is
not because of the fancy beds any hotel
can buy a fancy bed it's because the
people who work there that when you walk
the halls and somebody says hello you
get the distinct feeling that they
wanted to say hello not that they were
told to say hello we're highly attuned
social animals we can tell the
difference
anyway they happen to have a coffee bar
in the lobby
and I remember one one afternoon I went
and bought a cup of coffee you know and
the Barista working that day was a kid
named Noah and Noah was funny and
charming and engaging and I stood there
for far too long talking to Noah because
I just so enjoyed talking to him
and I remember
um I asked him you know uh uh do you
like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the challenge you
know I get paid well I like my job love
is emotional it's a higher order
connection like you know do you love
your wife I like her a lot right it's a
it's a different it's a different it's a
different thing
he said I love my I love my job so of
course my ears perked up
and I followed up and I said can you
tell me specifically what the Four
Seasons is doing that you would say to
me you love your job
and again he didn't have to think he
said yeah absolutely he says throughout
the day managers will walk past me and
check in on me ask me how I'm doing ask
me if there's anything else that I need
to do my job better he said not just my
manager any manager
and then he said I also worked for
another hotel
and there the managers walked past us
and catch us when we're doing things
wrong there they're driving performance
they want us to just make the numbers he
says there I like to keep my head below
the the radar and just get through the
day and collect my paycheck only at the
Four Seasons he said do I feel I can be
myself
now if you think about it this is the
exact same human being working at two
different companies and yet our
experience of him will be profoundly
different and his performance will be
profoundly different not because of the
person but because the leadership
environment in which he's working and
the number of times we blame the person
right I get this question all the time
you know how do I get the most out of my
people people aren't a towel you don't
ring them out
the better question is how do I create
an environment in which my people can
work at their natural best and that's
what the four seasons has learned to do
and so it's the exact same person I find
that profound
that usually if we have bad customer
service sometimes it is the person
without a doubt but it's amazing that if
there's a company that's plagued with
substandard performance or substandard
customer service or short-term
performance or they can't keep hold of
employees it's almost all rarely it's
almost never the people and almost
always the leadership environment
and so that's how we create trusting
teams
so much in that
in that catching them at their best that
asking how we can make the environment
better how do you do that in a virtual
world certainly there's surveys there's
actual conversations you can have but
that in the moment feedback that helps
people and the not my manager but maybe
a manager over here who observed me
doing a thing like there there's so much
to that of how do you replicate that and
not just leadership peers
right companies that have um uh robust
peer recognition
people feel that people will work much
harder for peer recognition than than
the recognition of their boss right
remember most systems are set up
that you only have to please one person
to advance your career
that's pretty much it right
but sis but companies that have robust
peer recognition programs are a real
sense of belonging and willingness to
sacrifice actually is more likely to
happen from the group so there's little
things and big things so little things
again we do this little things high five
on every meeting
we say remember high fives can happen at
any time right
um and so so anytime at any point at any
time we just randomly happens in random
meetings somebody says I need to give a
high five uh to Christy Christy you were
you stayed up late with me the other
night as I was struggling to get this
thing and I just want to say thank you
and it's done in a public forum
right it's done in a public forum where
I am I am expressing gratitude to you
and it feels good but it feels good to
everybody else and they want to work to
that standard as well there's more
robust things I've seen that other
companies do where
um they send out uh that time of year
they say which person on the team best
represents uh best uh uh exemplifies our
values this is not about performance
that you want to be more like
and people submit essays nominating
their peers and then a group of
volunteers read through all the essays
and then goes and interviews all the
nominees and then calls through it and
makes a decision as to who best
represents our values and they have a
um an event to announce it and they'll
read the letters they'll read the essay
submissions and there's always tears and
again pre-covet what these companies
would do is they would fly the parents
of the of the winner to come in and they
keep them hidden and when the winner was
announced they'd walk the parents in
because they want the parents to see the
kind of child they raised and that's
it's rarely the highest individual
performer
but this is somebody we all want to be
more alike and it makes us and nobody
you know when somebody gets a promotion
or a raise like there's like they don't
deserve it I deserve it in these cases
no one's angry we're all so grateful to
this person and we want to be more like
them so I think I I think pure
recognition
um like I said you can do it simply you
can do it complicated but having a
robust form of peer recognition is a
great way uh to build that sense of uh
of belonging and desire to contribute
even in a virtual world
I love it so many great ideas and I
would love to stay on this theme
um because we're going to shift sections
now what gives you hope for the future
we are in 52 card pickup land right now
with what work is going to look like
redefining relationships loyalty
connection there's creating trust
creating these amazing environments that
celebrate and uphold people's successes
what gives you hope and optimism for the
future
you know uh
like life it's a bumpy road you know the
then this is a bumpy road and you know
when covet first struck I I sort of I
smirked you know the all the Talking
Heads that said you know in these
uncertain times I'm like hold on
all times are uncertain there's never
been a time in history that was ever
certain every day is uncertain all that
happened is we went through a period of
calm that lulled you into a full sense
of security that there was certainty but
there never has been and there never
will be
and and so what gives me hope on this
bumpy road is that we're rejecting You
Know Jack Welch more Milton Friedman
ideas of what capitalism should look
like we're rejecting and asking
questions about shareholder Supremacy
um we're talking about
um uh uh that shareholders don't come
for us you know you have uh Larry Fink
writing letters about the importance of
purpose you know I mean look I wouldn't
have had a career in the 80s and 90s are
you kidding talking about why and
purpose I would have been laughed out of
you the purpose on like hippie dippy
stuff
you know I you know I I joke that you
know it's embarrassing that I have a
career you know there there should there
should be no demand I took a trust and
cooperation there should be no demand
but the fact that there is and people
want to talk about this and learn about
this the fact that it's a public
conversation we've talked about some
very mushy gooey things that are
perfectly acceptable conversations in
fact they have to be had in a work
environment
um and so I think a rejection of the 80s
and 90s form of capitalism the you know
where we over indexed on rugged
individualism and shareholder Supremacy
and profit before people
um and profit before purpose
um I you know gives me hope that even
though it's a bumpy road and we haven't
figured out what it'll look like I think
we're trending in the right direction
and and we're having those conversations
and the companies that are doing that
are the companies that we're
highlighting and wanting to work for so
I'm very optimistic
um so many powerful insights we have a
couple of audience questions for you
that will just go through Rapid Fire
what is the biggest thing that you've
learned while working remotely
oh great question
um for me the real one of the huge
insights is that we can have multiple
feelings at the same time
so you know when covet first started I
was in a period of massive pivoting and
reinvention like so many
um
um and as a creative person you know I I
chaos is my happy place I can't be there
sustainably the whole time but in
moments of chaos there is massive
creativity and so I was embarrassed
because I was having fun
um and yet around me was death and
destruction and bankruptcy and and I was
very torn like I can't be enjoying
myself I have to be I have to feel
sadness and guilt
um and as I went through my own
depression as I went through my own Dark
Days uh during covid you know uh could I
not be optimistic
and one of the huge things I've learned
I've learned as a human being is we
actually can have simultaneous feelings
we can have feelings at the same time
that our apparent opposite I can be sad
and excited at the same time
I can be depressed and optimistic at the
same time and so that's really helped me
um that I can have any feeling that I
feel in the moment that I'm feeling it
even if they seem like they're opposite
and I don't have to have an additional
feeling like guilt because I'm I should
rationally shouldn't have that feeling
at least the story I have in my head so
that's been really helpful to me not
only at work but it's been really
helpful to me in my personal life as
well just to have all the feels whenever
they happen
oh my gosh so much self-awareness in
that answer
um so you touched on we got to know you
in your start with why
um and so a question that we have for
you would you modify your start with Y
philosophy if you were to write a new
book that reflects the most recent
issues the pandemic has imposed on
society and business today
the simple answer is you know I I
believe in the scientific method I
believe in developing theories and when
I first articulated the concept of the
Golden Circle and start with why it was
a theory
and I set out to test it with looking
for opportunities for it to fail so I
kept I tried it and every I tried it in
government I tried it in a big business
small business B2B b2c I tried every
place I could go
wanting it to fail so I could so I could
improve upon it and so I love it when
there's chaos and things because I get
to test
um and I'm proud to say that the theory
holds up
um and if I were to go back and rewrite
the book I might change a couple of the
case studies because they're just a
little dated I change a little bit of
the language because it's a little dated
but uh but fundamentally
um I can say with great pride that that
the the theory the theory holds up and
it continues to serve me personally I
continue to to start with why and and
and lead with why to this very day
I love it
um
a question how do you reverse engineer
for a strong y or Collective goal
okay there's two two very different
things
um so uh you don't reverse engineer a
why
um why Discovery is objective
um you have as an individual you have
only one for your entire life and you
cannot change it and as a company
um you're supposed to have only one
although you can't break it uh uh where
but it always comes from the past you
know companies were started by Founders
a person or small group of people that
had a vision for something and were
driven by something and they took an
overwhelming risk of failure to do
something you know remember most new
businesses fail within the first three
years and yet somebody thought that
those odds were worth it
um and it's that drive and so uh a why
is objective it's about going back to
the past and asking where we come from
and then building upon that Foundation
um if you want you know an extreme
example the United States has a founding
story it's the Declaration of
Independence where we announced why we
needed to exist that all men are created
equal or people created equal endowed
with these unalienable rights and it's
we've been we've we've changed the
manner in which we've gone about it
we've tried to get better at it and we
know that it's a vision and it's an
ideal but in 200 nearly 250 years it
hasn't changed
it Still Remains where we come from and
the same is true for a company the same
is true for a person we are the sum
total of how we were raised by our
parents and the experiences we had when
we were young that formed us into who we
are and though we can act differently
um there's no changing fundamentally Who
We Are
I'm curious
have you seen any different Trends or
patterns uh it's showing up in all kinds
of places you know you have the lie down
movement uh in Asia
and so it is I think people are asking
questions I mean remember us in terms of
work you know so goes America so goes
the world because America's economy was
so large and because this country was so
rich a lot of Nations uh especially
developing economies copied how America
did things and so through the 80s and
90s and sort of Jack Welch sort of
theories of of leadership the rest of
the world uh followed
um uh and now that sort of America is
tipping the other direction there's a
correction
um I would expect that those that
followed our theories are going to tip
the same way so it's it's showing up
around the world it is a universal
um it's showing up in in different ways
but it's it's there it's definitely
there
the next question we have is about
Innovation innovation has an inherent
Financial writ and and operational risk
because failure is its most common
prequel in a risk averse organization
how do you promote investment in
Innovation when a positive outcome is
not guaranteed
well I mean asked and answered you don't
you know I remember talking to a company
I was talking to CFO and I asked him
what his priorities are and he said my
priorities are uh Innovation and
efficiency
uh he went well good luck with that you
know Innovation is inherently
inefficient because you try and fail you
try again
um and it's and you know if you have to
have a performance guarantee and you
have to demonstrate results of any
investment you know every single time in
the first year
then the simple answer is you're not an
Innovative company you know you're
putting lipstick on pigs
um you're making a screen bigger and
adding more memory but you're not
profoundly changing anything
um and you will always be a follower not
a leader so you know to ask me to
reconcile how you do it in that
environment the answer is you don't
um you perfect you have to have a
profoundly different tolerance for risk
for uh to have Innovation now that
doesn't mean you have to shift the
entire company the way to do it is
entrepreneurially which is
um where big more risk-averse companies
can still innovate or not even just big
ones the risk-averse companies can still
innovate is you create entrepreneurial
Ventures where you put somebody who if
they succeed they're going to make their
career and if they fail they might break
their career but they like those odds
um and you take them outside of the the
you take them outside of the um the
standard hierarchy they report only to
the CEO who gives them you know and if
there's inefficiencies like if they hire
somebody we already have somebody for
that they want to hire a different
supplier but we delete you leave them be
they manage their own budget they do
whatever they want and you treat it as
if it's its own thing then then then you
can have Innovation that way but it's
ostensibly an entrepreneurial venture
within this within the company
um but yeah no you the answer is you
don't
okay
um we're gonna do some rapid fire uh
what was your first job
uh my first job I worked in advertising
I worked as a competitive analyst in a
large agency
okay what is not on your LinkedIn
profile uh uh
I don't know
it's just like you know are you like a
fantastic spaghetti maker oh uh I oh
okay
um
you know I make um I make really great
salmon
I I can make salmon like five ways I
like I love I love cooking fish
okay that's that's your party trick
that's what you bring today yeah if
anybody wants salmon I'm Your Man
um do you have a great book
recommendation for us
um
so James cars who wrote finite infinite
games
uh before he died I had the opportunity
to spend some time with him and he wrote
many many books and I asked him what's
the best book you ever wrote uh you know
I wanted to know and I thought he was
going to say finite infinite games
because it's so freaking brilliant in
its concept
um uh but he said the best book he ever
wrote was
um uh a religious case against belief
and I started reading it just out of
curiosity because you know one of these
people that I love and admire Dr cars
this is his favorite book that he wrote
and I like I got through the first five
pages and I had to go back and reread it
again because it was so dense it made my
head hurt and so if you like things that
make your head hurt and you want and if
you like having your your assumptions
challenged and you like sort of
philosophical rabbit holes uh
it was it's very interesting
I now know what I'm getting for my
father for his birthday this year thank
you so much
um Simon thank you so much for the time
for the insight for your perspective
you are so
um
you are such a leading mind in the space
and I think in the you know in the
course of this time I felt all the feels
they were mushy gushy I didn't feel at
all hippie dippy and I felt very
validated and hopefully the same for our
audience as well so thank you so much
for your time I really appreciate it it
was a pleasure to talk to you today
thanks so much for having me I'm I'm
really glad you heard all the fields uh
take care of yourself and take care of
each other